Speaker 1: Hey, I want to briefly tell you about
the fact that one of the accused Trump rioters
was out on bail and killed a young mother in a
drunk driving crash. Now, why is this story of
particular importance? Why would I highlight
this story? For six years, Trump is to have
been talking about undocumented immigrants out on
bail in the country are committing this crime and
that crime, and these are just terrible, terrible
people. Imagine if the situation here was reversed
and some left wing BLM protester out on bail
killed someone in a drunk driving accident.
What would be happening on Fox News right now?
But a version of that is what happened here.
Emily Hernandez infamously appeared in
photos carrying a broken sign from the
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi's office. This was
a Trump rider. It's beyond beyond question.
Twenty two year old woman, oh boy, all of a sudden
I'm having a problem reading this article. I guess
I need a Daily Beast subscription, which I don't
have. OK? Twenty two year old woman Trump rioter
out on bail. Drunk driving kills a young mother,
and I want to go through the numerous hypocrisies
here. For decades, the right hasn't cared about
conditions in jails or prisons. If you're there,
you must have done something wrong. You deserve
it. We don't coddle people. We aren't Norway with
nice jails. Now it's Trumpists because some of
them because of their role in the Jan. six riots
and they are saying they're
being treated terribly.
The prison and jail conditions are terrible.
The vegan guy's not getting his vegan food.
Since when do you care about conditions in prisons
and jails? These Trumpists, they can't mount
good defenses if they are stuck in pretrial
detention all the way up until their trial,
right? We've been saying that about all sorts
of offenders, including relatively low level
drug offenders held without bail, unable to
mount a proper defense. And you didn't care.
Now you care because it's Trumpists, and then
it's. We can't let illegals out on bail. Then
they go and commit crimes. Even though we know
undocumented immigrants commit crime at a lower
rate than natural born American citizens. And then
here we go. Here is a Trump rider out on bail,
gets drunk and kills someone driving around in
a car. The reality is either you're a danger and
you need to be in custody or you're not, and you
should be out until you appear in court or have
to report to prison or whatever the case may be.
This doesn't have to take on the political nature.
The reason we are pointing out the political
nature is number one, because these are issues
that the right has first ignored. And now all
of a sudden they care about. Where is we on? The
Left have cared about these important issues for
a really long time pretrial detention bail, etc.
and number two. Because they only are
paying attention when it affects one side,
these people truly are pathetic and they're silent
on this particular issue. Just imagine if this was
a BLM protester or someone from Antifa what you
would be seeing on right wing media right now.
Let's take a quick break. We'll be back
right after this. Much more to cover today.